one of the facts about cartoons in the
distant past is that a lot of people
were illiterate and that had to do with
class but they were not blind and they
could see images and they could
understand cartoons which have a
language of their own so that I think
one of the reasons that everyone from
King Philippe was upset with dome yeas
and fili pawns caricatures of him as
lawar the pair
he knew the masses were seeing these
things and were making judgments about
him right up until boss tweed who
famously said of Thomas Nast cartoons I
don't care what they write about me but
get rid of those damn pictures poetic
justice when boss tweed was traveling in
Spain and on the lam in effect he was
turned in by people who had recognized
him from Thomas nests caricatures of him
one of the interesting things in life is
that there is as Columbia's
neuroscientist Eric Kandel would tell
you there are experiments which show
that people recognize caricatures before
they recognize the actual photographs of
the real people cartoons speak in a
visual language of their own and you
can't answer them with words and one of
the reasons that I think people get so
upset by cartoons or the people who
identify with the victims of the
caricature is that they there is no if
you don't like an article you can write
a letter to the editor even if it's only
in your head if you don't like a
caricature of you there is no such thing
as a caricature to the editor or cartoon
to the editor unless you happen to be a
brilliant caricatures and then the
second reason is so people feel impotent
because they don't know how to answer it
the second reason is the suspicion that
this caricatures may be right he may
have caught the real me
I am this avaricious greedy person he
portrays David Louis cartoons of Adolf
Hitler were quite sweet he showed them
to be an object of fun and yet every
time one of them came out Hitler would
call a meeting of his General Staff and
he would go through the roof and later
the chairman of the board of the paper
that David Lowe was writing for it was
doing his cartoons for in London
actually paid a visit to Germany because
they banned his magazine they asked them
how they could get his paper to be
unbanned he said fired David Lowe is but
it was that simple dictators like these
guys they don't object to be seen as
horrific monster world beaters they want
to beat their chests and show the world
be afraid of me when you show them to be
fools and idiots and jerks and buffoons
in effect that's what they really object
to it
I think people always read their own
paranoia their own fears their own hopes
into works of art and cartoons make
statements that people can accept in
different ways the famous one The New
Yorker cover by Barry blit showing the
Obamas doing a fist bump dressed in
camouflage terrorist uniforms to
caricature right-wing views of the
Obamas a lot of people took it to be a
statement that's what the Obamas were
that they were terrorists and most of
the regular New Yorker readers
understood what the cover was but it was
some many who saw it in other forms who
got outraged by it and then some New
Yorker readers cancel their
subscriptions because of it in 30 years
that the nation only was did the staff
march on my office with a petition
demanding that we not publish something
what they protested was a cartoon with
the petition by David Levine and it was
a caricature of Henry Kissinger at the
time of the Caribbean Basin report a
young woman who is our assistant
circulation manager actually said was
that the nation is supposed to be
against stereotypes this cartoon shows
sex as something that an active male on
top does to a passive woman on bottom
we're supposed to be against that I said
well yes that is the stereotype that it
draws on to show what to make David
Levine's comment but we ran it and we
ran a long exchange of letters about it
but the obvious thing didn't occur to me
that it was a cartoon that was
politically incorrect rather than just a
proposition and that I didn't focus on
until the Danish muhammad's came along
and and I realized that the caricatures
and and the fact of the images was at
the heart of it and when I began to look
into it I saw that going back in history
from domi a right up to a few years ago
when a Palestinian cartoonist was
assassinated on the streets of London
that people have you can say overreacted
but reacted to cartoons with deep
emotional reaction and I wanted to know
why and I wanted to collect examples of
it and I wanted to rethink some things
that had happened to me and my own
experience as an editor who dealt with a
lot of great artists